DYLAN THOMAS: Hello, welcome
to What In The World.
This is a regular show where
enterprise Geo Googlers tell
you a little bit more about an
interesting part of enterprise
Maps products.
My name is Dylan Thomas, I'm
a Community Maps Manager.
And with me today
is Graeme Merrall,
who's a Deployment Engineer.
Hi Graeme.
GRAEME MERRALL: Hi, Dylan.
DYLAN THOMAS: And
today I think you're
going to tell us some really
interesting, handy tips
about data integration.
GRAEME MERRALL: That's right.
So a lot of people when they
go down the GIS road, generally
start using Google Earth to
manage their data because it's
simple and it has
a great interface.
But one of the restrictions
with Google Earth it
that it uses a
format called KML,
which is an XML format
used by Google Earth.
It's a very rich
format, but it generally
allows users to insert
unstructured data along
with the content.
And the problem when you move
to a system like Google Maps
Engine is that you require
structured data to get access
to the attributes.
DYLAN THOMAS: So you might
start with something simple
like an HTML table.
And it looks fine
on the map, but then
when you're saying when you
move into an enterprise system
you need structured data.
That becomes a
problem at that point.
GRAEME MERRALL: That's correct.
And you can actually see in the
example that I've got up here,
I've got some mountains
from New Zealand,
which is my home country.
And if we click on
this window, you
can see we get a nice piece
of some HTML that pops up.
But it's actually
represented in the KML access
as actually HTML that's
completely unstructured.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
So if we were going to
look at this-- I mean,
you're saying it's HTML code.
Which is fine if you
want to look at it,
but it's pretty horrible if
you want to try and import that
into some other system.
GRAEME MERRALL: That's right.
You can actually see
in this screenshot
I've got up, we actually
can see the underlying KML
and what it looks like.
You can see it just
looks like HTML.
And so if we import
that into Maps Engine,
you can see all we get
is the description field.
We're actually not able
to do anything with it.
So we can't style it and filter
it, or anything like that.
And that's obviously a problem,
because the whole point
of wanting to get structured
data into KML and into Maps
Engine is that you
want to actually
be able to do that sort
of filtering and styling.
So one of the things you can do
is to change or alter the way
that you use to create
or manage your KML.
And so there's two
methods for doing that.
The first is to use something
called extended data.
And extended data drops
out this description field
by creating essentially
a set of name value pairs
that you include
inside your KML.
And then to replace
that description window,
you create something
called a Balloon Style.
Now the nice thing
about that is you
just defined it once at
the top of the document,
and then every other piece of
content gets to reuse that.
So it makes it much simpler
to manage and change it.
We can have a quick look at
some KML, just show you that.
Here's one showing the Balloon
Style I just briefly mentioned.
And you can see some
placeholders in there
with square brackets.
And so that data is going
to get transplanted up
from a placeholder, a placemark.
So you can see now we've
got an extended data field.
We have a data name.
And you can see we have the
display name, and the value.
And also for the height,
we have the display name,
and the value.
DYLAN THOMAS: Ah,
so it's structured,
but then the other part,
too, is that you're only
defining that display
style in one place.
So you're not replicating
the display style
for every single
placemark, you're just
doing it once-- the
balloon, I should say.
GRAEME MERRALL: That's
right, that's right.
So well, I would say there's,
again, in the classic method,
if you wanted to change
the format of the table,
you would have to change
every single placemark.
And this one, you
just change it once.
And it ripples through
every single change.
Now if we look at
Google Earth, we
can see that, actually, it
doesn't look any different.
From a user point of view, it
looks as good as it ever did.
DYLAN THOMAS: So
we're done, right?
We've got structured data.
So what does it look like
in the Maps Engine, then?
GRAEME MERRALL:
Well, the problem
with our fantastic
structured data
is it imports only as a string.
See, here's now
the data that I've
converted using extended data,
and imported into Maps Engine.
But now everything has
gone in as a string.
So now the height field
is actually a number,
it's 2797 meters,
or what have you.
So because it's a
string, you can't
perform basic comparisons,
like greater than or less than.
So ideally you want to be able
to import numbers as numbers
and dates as dates and
strings as strings.
It just makes good sense.
So you have to search
for an alternate style
to make that happen.
And that's using something
called schema data.
And schema data
inside KML allows
you to type your content.
And it's actually
slightly simpler
than using extended data.
The way you do it is you still
define your balloon style,
but then you create
something at the top--
you can see
highlighted in red --we
create something
called a schema.
And you can see,
now we've defined
something called a mountain
name of type string,
and defined a
height of type int.
And you can also see
I've altered the display
name slightly for
mountain height,
so it's actually--
you can actually
sort of pack in whatever sort
of data you like in there.
You can even put [INAUDIBLE].
DYLAN THOMAS: Nice.
Can you store-- can you do
dates as well, for example?
Are there other types there, or
is it just numbers and strings?
GRAEME MERRALL: There's
about eight different types
you can store.
So string, int, date,
floats, real numbers,
all sorts of things.
We'll include a URL to point
you to the documentation that
covers this, so you can read
about the different types
that it's imported.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great
GRAEME MERRALL: So we can
also now see a placemark,
and you can see we
have extended data.
And now we have the schema data
takes and simple data takes.
And you can see
it's very simple.
It's just simple name,
value, name, value.
DYLAN THOMAS: Much
cleaner, yeah.
GRAEME MERRALL: All
right, so it actually
makes that placemark very, very
simple and clean to look at.
DYLAN THOMAS: And it
all looks the same
in Google Earth, right?
There's no difference
to the consumer?
GRAEME MERRALL: That's right.
So if you go back to Google
Earth and turn this one on,
you can see again, it
looks exactly the same.
I've changed the formatting,
so I apologize slightly.
But you can see again, we've
got [INAUDIBLE] 2797 meters,
as it should do.
If we look at the data types,
there it is again, same thing.
So it's no different
to the end user.
But if we go ahead and have
a look now in Maps Engine,
I'll just go a bit
through my search results,
we now have our
content and our height
correctly in as a number.
So now we can start
to do that comparison.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah, excellent.
And so you're recommending
the use of a library
to do some of this work, right?
GRAEME MERRALL: That's correct.
So one of the
things-- particularly
if you've already got
a whole bunch of KML
where you've got content
in the description field
--you need to get
that out and turn it
into, say, an extended data
field where you can import.
You need to
actually-- obviously,
it's far simpler to do
that programmatically.
So we have a great tool which
is written by a Googler,
but it's open
source, called pyKML.
And it makes it very easy to
read and write and also enter
KML files.
Now one of the things
that's nice about it,
is that you actually
just reference the names.
So you can see
about halfway down,
you can see the slide
that begins with four.
And what it's doing is, I've
said for every placemark,
and then KML-- the XML to
find a point or a line that
says placemark.
And so I just use
the word placemark
to say find every
placemark in my KML file.
DYLAN THOMAS: It's
almost like you're
reading KML at that point.
If you insert some angle
brackets, it's the same thing.
GRAEME MERRALL:
Yeah, it's almost
like reading KML in Python.
And then you can
just open up-- you
just have a look
at the description
field, which is in Python
called description.
And it depends on
your situation so you
can read the contents
of that field.
And then you just write it
back using extended data.
So I've said here
in the line here,
that says
Fragment.ExtendedData.append.
So [INAUDIBLE] in
pyKML say create
a field called extended data
and append some KML to it.
And if you flip
back in the video
and have a look at the
XML, or the KML for this,
you'll actually see it actually
matches up very simply.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh, excellent.
So in the description
field, you said
this is sort of a custom, or
case by case basis, right?
So when you actually
get the description,
then, obviously you
might need to use
another library or some special
logic to take your content
and turn it into the
structured data you want.
But at that point, you're just
writing it out using pyKML.
GRAEME MERRALL:
Yeah, that's right.
So how you actually crack
open the description field
and read your data out
is gonna pin entirely
on how you've got that in there.
If it's much tabular
data, it's going
to be quite easy to use a simple
HTML library to read that.
If it's just in this
bullet point, so something
a little bit more
free-form, you're
gonna have a bit more of
a struggle to do that.
The alternative of
course, is if the data
is stored in a
database of some sort,
you can actually
just write some pyKML
to actually create
KML from scratch.
You don't need to crack
open a KML file and edit it.
You can just dump it
out from your database,
using the pyKML
library to create
a brand new KML with
all [INAUDIBLE].
DYLAN THOMAS: That's a
really good idea, yeah.
Well, Graeme, I've got one
other question for you then.
So you popped up the
URL for pyKML briefly,
we'll put that in the video.
But is there a good source
for getting some real world
examples of this in action, so
our customers can take a look
and get a head start?
GRAEME MERRALL: Yeah,
so the pyKML website
includes a lot of
different examples
for reading, writing,
and editing KML,
both simple and complex.
So you can manage very
large structured data of KML
if you wish.
And also through
the pyKML website
there's actually a
mailing list as well.
So if you've got
any questions that
aren't answered by the examples,
from reading the documentation,
by all means, jump short.
If you jump on the
mailing list, you'll
likely get your question
answered there as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: Excellent, great.
Well Graeme, thanks
very much indeed,
really useful information here.
And we will make sure we
include the links in the video,
and we'll see you next
time on What In The World.